well you've been listening there to
russian president vladimir putin
addressing the media at a solo press
conference
after wrapping up talks in geneva with
u.s president joe biden
he did confirm that they discussed
security trade relations human rights
cyber security as well as the issue of
crimea and the militarization of the
arctic
president putin was clear he says there
was no animosity between the two men and
while there are still areas of
disagreement he's confident
they'll be able to find some common
ground within their pragmatic
relationship
he described biden as a constructive
experienced partner and says they spoke
the same language
they had a frank and candid discussion
well let's bring in our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott who's
also been listening in she's at those
talks
in geneva kimberly as expected these
were fairly wide-ranging talks i mean
that's
a lot to cram into just a few hours and
putin did appear to be in fairly good
spirits there
it does appear they covered a lot of
common ground and
you know it's important that we take
into context there's still one more
press conference to be held
from the u.s president joe biden in
order to get the complete picture
of what exactly was agreed upon in that
room but
the takeaways from the russian leader
vladimir putin is that there are some
news headlines
that it appears can be reported
including that they appear to have
agreed to return diplomats to their
respective
countries that had been expelled in this
tit-for-tat expulsion of diplomats
earlier this year
the timeline apparently still being
worked out between the various
governments not only the state
department but also the respective
agency
inside of russia as well it appears that
the extension of the arms control treaty
new start
may have some discussions and
consultations to extend that even
further uh and we also know that with
respect to
the issue of ukraine that it appears
that
uh well there was a number of questions
about this and there was quite a bit of
discussion one would presume behind
closed doors
it didn't appear that the russian leader
was
that forthcoming on some of the concerns
that the west has with respect to the
military buildup along ukraine's border
in fact
he dodged that i would say saying that
he was just conducting
military exercises and that this is
something that is in accordance with
international law and kimberley he was
also confronted by
several members of the media about
navalny and the opposition crackdown
in in russia but it seems he really
didn't budge an engine
rather instead shared some of his own
views about politics in the united
states
well he seemed to say uh you're really
one to be
pointing the finger when the uh you know
the old saying goes there are three
other fingers that are pointing back at
you
highlighting some of the uncomfortable
truths about
us and it's its struggle with democracy
as well
he referenced the black lives matter
movement that at times has
has been uh very uh disruptive in the
united states as they continue to
advance again and to
to protest against systemic racism in
the united states
uh pointing out the fact that there have
been as he said
people are being trained to throw
molotov cocktails he likened the
sort of opposition protests in russia as
being
very similar to the demonstrations we've
seen played out on u.s streets he also
pointed to the fact that
there is a problem with policing and
police reform needed in the united
states that people
can be uh shot in the back with the sort
of alleged impunity and
certainly this is something the united
states is working on so the argument
being made is that
can you really point the finger and i
think the most telling part of that
in reference and defense to the argument
that
concerns about alexey navalny the
russian opposition leader who is
currently in jail many concerned he
could die
in prison is the fact that
leading up to this summit the name
calling that occurred between
joe biden and vladimir putin joe biden
calling putin
a killer well was answered very squarely
saying that
joe biden called him and this is how he
explained himself he was satisfied with
that explanation
and he pointed to history and the drone
attacks that have occurred in
afghanistan
on civilians these strikes that have
occurred and he said who's the killer
now
well that is an uncomfortable truth for
the united states that there have been
accusations of
extrajudicial killing so he really was
very
good at some of those uncomfortable
issues whether it be ukraine whether it
be alexi navalny
of redirecting and pointing the
arguments back saying
is this the u.s uh great history of
respecting human rights
essentially saying i don't think so so
those are some difficult conversations
that were likely had and
this is certainly evidence of him
dodging the questions if you will well
speaking of trying to turn the tables
and point the finger the other way we
did expect that
cyber attacks were going to be discussed
clearly they were
and it does appear that there will be
more consultations now going forward
yes but as you point out there was the
turning of the tables on that answer as
well
it really we saw putin not accepting
responsibility for the
safe harbor that the united states is
accusing russia
if not being behind those attacks that
have affected the colonial pipeline
that have certainly harmed american
businesses and
what he essentially said was well those
those are occurring
in the united states it's happening in
canada it's happening in latin america
but the united states intelligence
agents say it's happening in russia
and if this is not state-sponsored then
certainly there is knowledge of it
happening in the kremlin
and that the russia has a responsibility
to see that it stops so
he didn't appear to acknowledge any
responsibility in any way but to say
that there would be consultation
moving forward kimberly halcott our
white house correspondent
covering all of that for us from geneva
thank you so much kimberly
well as kimberly was mentioning russian
president vladimir putin says those
talks with
u.s president joe biden were
constructive despite many divergent
positions
there has been no hostility on the
contrary our meeting took place in a
constructive spirit
indeed we have varied assessments on a
number of issues but both sides
expressed the intention to understand
each other
and seek common ground talks were quite
constructive
and as we were just discussing both
sides appear to have agreed for their
ambassadors to return to their
respective countries
with regards to the return of our
ambassadors to their workplaces
the return of the american ambassador to
moscow and our ambassador to washington
we agreed that they would return to
their duties
as for the timeline tomorrow or the day
after that's a technicality
we agree that our foreign services will
start consultations on a number of
issues
well let's now bring in our diplomatic
editor james bayes he's been watching
all of this
from london james successful talks it
really feels like
most things here went to plan
yes i mean i i think certainly there are
some things that have been agreed
and certainly if you look at the very
big picture uh the strategic discussions
moving on from new start
nuclear um the nuclear policy regarding
these two major nuclear powers clearly
we should all be a little relieved
that they are talking about that and
potentially going to talk further
on that and certainly in terms of the
tone of the talks that orcs seem to have
gone well
as they were described there by vladimir
putin but in that news conference you
very much i think saw
the two sides of the russian leader you
saw the diplomat
certainly talking about joe biden as
constructive well-balanced
seasoned politician saying he saw his
qualities and his moral
values uh saying that they were frank
and productive talks
and the talks went uh and were to the
point in his view
that was one side of vladimir putin but
of course when he's challenged on things
and he was on human rights in russia and
the opposition in russia
he punches back and a very different
sort of vladimir putin with a long
rambling answer uh in response to that
challenge about navalny
notice he never says um navalny's name
the man you have mentioned he says in
response to the question
and then comparing it with all sorts of
ills going back to
uh to iraq and afghanistan
right the way forward to this year as
kimberly mentioned to the january vi
protests talking about human rights in
the united states and who is the killer
now
and i think in some ways this is down to
two different things that the russians
want out of these sort of gatherings
yes most diplomats believe russia rather
like the last four years it liked
the chaos of the trump administration it
liked the disunity
among the western allies but there's
something else that russia likes and
that's being talked to
and being at the top table it likes
being a permanent member
of the un security council it likes the
gravitas
that president putin gets with a meeting
from president biden so
the two sides of vladimir putin and i
think the two
objectives of russian diplomacy which
are somewhat dissimilar
well james putin also mentioned this
glimpse of hope for mutual trust but
i noticed there haven't been any
invitations to the white house or
kremlin for either man
do we have a sense of where the
discussions might go from here
well i think the answer is that the
diplomats will tell you
the important thing is that discussions
continue in some way
because you need to have a process and
you need to have regular meetings and
clearly
the spiral was going downwards
with diplomats on both sides being
expelled and then more recently both of
the ambassadors
effectively leaving their capitals and
one returning to moscow one returning
to washington i think if you can get the
diplomats back and the ambassadors back
you can at least start
a dialogue even if they don't agree on
things
but a major change in russian u.s
relations i think that's unlikely
vladimir putin has been in power for two
decades more than two decades
and he's not going to change and he's
certainly despite the fact he says he
saw
uh president biden's qualities and moral
values
uh certainly uh the values of russia and
vladimir putin
are not what would be described as u.s
values
james you've covered so many talks like
these but today we're seeing separate
press conferences
after these discussions which is pretty
unusual right should we be reading into
that
no i don't think so i i think i'll be
totally frank with you i think
u.s officials if they could talk to you
privately will say
they didn't want president biden who is
a very very experienced statesman
who certainly knows how to deal with
these things um
in terms of a meeting face to face but
they didn't want him surprised by
by a cunning president putin in a news
conference
uh he is uh the oldest u.s
president and sometimes he has uh the
habit of misspeaking
i think they thought it was safer to
have separate news conferences and not
in some way be ambushed they also i
think have the memory of what happened
and it was in july of 2018 so nearly
three years ago of that press conference
with donald trump and vladimir putin and
certainly
that was a news conference that we all
going to remember i remember covering it
in helsinki and really
not believing the words in my ear as i
listened to that news conference live
remember on that occasion president
trump sided with president putin
disputing all of the u.s intelligence
agencies that russia
had interfered in the us uh in the u.s
presidential election
i think that memory even though it's a
completely different administration
they could see the perils of a of a
joint news conference
and that's why they went down this route
of single news conferences
and we're having a little pause now
before president biden speaks to the
press
i think that's probably because they're
digesting some of the
um comments from the russian leader
seeing how they're going to respond to
some of the questions about some of the
things he said
i think the protocol department of the
us have done rather well out of this
getting the second
news conference it's always best to come
second and being able
to respond and also of course president
biden um
when he arrived here he arrived second
and i think they were worried that in
the past president putin has turned up
at some of these
summits late and left the person he was
meeting standing around rather awkwardly
and so the protocol department and
they're the people in all these
diplomatic gatherings who make sure
everything
is timed and choreographed to the second
i think the us
might have at least won that diplomatic
battle today
well everything very well choreographed
indeed out diplomatic editor james bay
is there
across that for us from london thank you
so much james well let's now bring in
kurt volcker
he is the former u.s special
representative for ukraine negotiations
as well as a former ambassador to nato
he joins us now
from bratislava kurt so no breakthrough
but some success especially given that
both sides were really playing down
expectations now
i want to ask you as someone who's
previously been involved
in negotiations on ukraine what did you
make of putin's response when it came to
that question
well i think that vladimir putin is
essentially still continuing a
narrative of denial saying that russia
is really just a
facilitator or a mediator in the
conflict and not really the main
protagonist in the conflict
and therefore in a position saying yes
of course we support peace in ukraine
meaning that he sees it all as ukraine's
responsibility
well there was also talk of the
militarization of the arctic
um nato i imagine we'll be watching all
of that very closely
yeah i think so and i think putin was
actually a little bit amusing here
he was welcoming people into russian
territory saying well this is all
russian uh there are territorial
disputes over what is russian and what
is not in the arctic
but saying that of course this is an
important issue and russia has
territorial areas but we are willing to
cooperate
i was just talking to our two
correspondents about the dynamic
and we know that biden has obviously
been pretty outspoken about
putin in the past calling him a killer
that very
notorious line and as we reminded today
he even told putin that he didn't have a
soul
back in 2011. what did you make of the
dynamic between the two men today
well uh clearly president biden wanted
to strike a tone of
being willing to try to work together if
putin is willing to try to work together
and to de-escalate tensions and as the
divide administration said repeatedly
try to create a more stable and
predictable relationship
so the surface dynamics here are that
biden conveyed that
image from the united states and i think
president putin is trying to convey
a similar heir of or tone
if you will yes yes you know we are
willing to
uh work together we want to de-escalate
as well
but the substance of what putin is
saying is that he denies responsibility
for what russia is doing
puts more blame on others in the united
states and
is going to continue some of the
activities that he has been doing such
as the
aggression against ukraine well speaking
of that trying to shift the
responsibility i'm curious as to where
you think the conversations will then go
on cyber security because obviously that
was going to be a huge chunk of the
discussions today
where does that go from here well it was
very interesting
one of the answers he gave was to say
that the preponderance of cyber security
attacks are coming from the united
states so this is really a u.s
problem and i think what this indicates
again is a denial of responsibility
if you know much about russia you know
that groups don't exist and carry out
activities without the russian
government tolerating it
and some of the attacks we've had
against the us including critical
infrastructure came from there
and putin is clearly just deflecting
that